so what yeah what we got here then
what's this
playing around with this quite fun uh i
borrowed this from our robot lab this is
an intel realsense which is a kind of
all-in-one depth sensor right so i
thought we'd just talk about what it is
and why might we want depth in the
vision literature which is sort of where
i am we would usually term this rgbd
right which is red green and blue and
also depth right now depth is
kind of like 3d in the sense that you
know where things are in a scene but
actually really you just know how far
they are away from the camera which is
not as good as 3d because of course you
don't know what's behind those things
but it's better perhaps than just rgb
because it allows you to for example
separate objects much much more easily
quite a lot of research is going on
in rgbd just in general because it makes
a lot of problems slightly easier or
more powerful you know deep learning
applied to rgbd is traditionally going
to be a bit better performing than just
rgb because the network doesn't have to
make that effort to separate where the
object boundaries are you could just
find the thing that's closest and do
that right that it would theoretically
make it easier now actually i don't do a
lot of real sense only because i only
got this yesterday but and i probably
have to give it back but you know maybe
if i do a really good video they'll let
me keep it um but i thought we'd talk
about you know what why has it got four
things on it you know how does this
relate to for example the connect that
everyone knows famously that was one of
the first things to do this and
what's new and interesting about this
kind of technology well let's demo it
first right so i've got my intel
realsense viewer here i've made almost
no effort right so i haven't installed
the sdk i'm not using this with code
although you can do this i'm just going
to turn on the stereo camera
and now it's booted up you can actually
see it's pretty good right i mean you
know when you get closer yeah that's
working it's working that's not bad i
can see i can see the microphone and the
i've got my hand in the way now um and
then you're behind it over here and you
can just generally see that there's a
kind of
wall behind you that's kind of the shape
that i would expect if i turn on the
camera as well
you can see that this is kind of what
the scene is looking at there's sean
yeah so i mean it works pretty well now
people who are expecting a perfect depth
map might be surprised that there's a
little bit of missing stuff here and
perhaps we can talk a bit about the
technology stereo is in some sense to
solve problem in the sense that this is
very good right very fast it's never
going to be perfect right there's a few
reasons for this
mostly it comes down to essentially you
can't see everything with both eyes and
so
you know on the left here there's a huge
gap and that's because the right camera
can't see that bit of a scene and so we
can't resolve any kind of depth there
it's the same thing of when you hold
your finger up and you actually see two
fingers right if i'm looking at you and
i'm looking at my finger through my
finger i can see two fingers
you kind of ignore that because you're
used to it but those things appear as
artifacts in this kind of image
so how does this work well i'll turn it
off um
so what we've got is we've got four
sensors on here these two are cameras
here um the left camera and the right
camera all right i am that is correct
it's just because they're from my point
of view not from your point of view
right this is an ir dot pattern emitter
which just splashes dot pattern and
we'll talk about that and then this is
the actual rgb camera right now what the
whole point of the real sense is that it
does rgb d so it will it knows where
these cameras are
on its pcb it's been calibrated and that
means when it produces a depth
map it can also attach rgb values to
those exact pixels right by knowing
where this sits compared to these now we
talked about stereo in a different video
and it was about matching between images
in general the idea of stereo is you
have some pixels in your left image for
example and you try and find the
corresponding position in your right
image and you use triangulation to work
out then how far away they are now in
this setup that's a lot easier because
these cameras are fixed they're very
well calibrated and essentially they're
level with each other so
basically the algorithm just needs to
look where you are on the left and look
left and right in the right image until
it finds the corresponding matching
feature
and work out the depth and it does that
with respect to the left image so it
goes it starts in the left image
fighting for all pixels it looks in the
right image to find out which pixels um
correspond to them and then what the
depth is
and it will also be doing some stuff to
do with smoothing and things like that
generally i mean we mentioned this in a
stereo video but generally scenes like
your camera has got a lot of different
depths but this wall doesn't right and
so it can produce smoother things on the
wall right this is not an interesting
wall
um i should put some artwork up or
something anyway so what does this dot
pattern do well one of the problems with
stereo is that you need features to
match you need to be able to say okay i
found these pixels that look like this
and in the right image they're over here
but if your pixels are all a white wall
that becomes really quite difficult to
do and so what the connect introduced
was this ir dot pattern so essentially
you can you can you can see pictures of
this online with people who've got ir
sensitive cameras looking at this but it
just splashes a sort of semi-random
pseudo-random pattern of dots over
everything
and the kinect directly used that to
work out what the depth was based on the
warping of those dots so you'd see the
pattern obviously differently on a flat
surface to a yeah
yes and and for example if the pattern
looks small and far away it's small and
far away like something like that right
the pattern is a of a known structure
and so when that structure changes you
can say okay that's because of the depth
this is not quite the same as this this
uses the infrared as an optional
additional texture that can help but
it's not mandatory right so what that
means is
that this camp these cameras see both
the scene but also a load of dot pattern
that's put everywhere if it's there and
they can use that to say okay i
definitely am pretty sure even on this
white wall
these two positions match right and we
can see this actually
if i plug this back in
so if i put this in here right so this
looks pretty good what this is now using
stereo matching between both images and
it's also using the infrared dot pattern
to provide additional texture if i cover
up one of the cameras
we lose the depth
obviously right it's just a camera now
it doesn't work if i take the camera
back it comes back in right it's quite
robust actually it didn't crash anything
i had written to do this would have
probably broken um
if i cover up the infrared dot pattern
which i'm sort of guessing where that is
it's over here right
then you can see
that the depth still works but it's much
much worse than it was before and that's
because now
we only have the two cameras we're just
doing the best we can with what we've
got so areas like you where you've got
quite a lot of texture are still
actually pretty good
right it's worse but it's not bad
the wall over there which is essentially
plain white has basically started to
completely fail over here on the corner
because there's nothing really of
interest on that wall if i take my
finger off
we can see suddenly it's much much much
better because on this white wall
this infrared pattern is really really
helping right so this is what makes this
quite a cool little device
is it first of all it doesn't crash when
i cover up one of the cameras which i
like just as the software engineer me
thinks that's good but it's optional
right so some of the real sensors don't
have an infrared emitter
but this one has its optional infrared
emitter where if it works it can help if
it doesn't work you get some depth back
outside infrared is much less effective
you can imagine against the sun this dot
pattern is essentially not visible so
when you're outside you're going to fall
back to normal stereo vision the other
thing to mention is that no processing
is being done on my laptop at all right
so my laptop the fans aren't spinning up
it's having to display this on the
screen but it's not having to work very
hard and that's because all of a stereo
matching all of the use of infrared and
all of the rgb
you know alignment is being done on this
device
which of course is exactly what we want
right and that was actually one of the
first things that connect did
and then and since then all these other
devices that do much the same thing
because if you have to use one of your
cores on your computer to do the actual
matching then suddenly that matching is
going to slow down when your computer's
under load it's just a complete pain
it's nice to have a camera that just
gives you a depth sensing without having
to do a load of extra work to get it
right but of course other depth sensing
technologies like lidar timer flight
lasers and things like this which are
perhaps arguably more accurate more
expensive i mentioned that deep learning
for example would be better in
rgbd so you actually it's quite common
so for example one of the things we're
looking at um is object saliency which
is how imp you know where are the
important objects in an image and in
object saliency there are various data
sets but there are also rgbd data sets
which are essentially the same but they
also have depth information and it
depends on how the data set was captured
and actually this is true of a lot of
fields where you've got some data sets
in rgb some data sets in rgbd and you
know the techniques for rgbd as you
imagine are pretty similar right they
might vary slightly so for example if
you've got a normal three channel image
then if you remember what you put into a
deep network you would normally have rgb
and we represent these as planes of
image now actually of course thinking
back to one of my first videos maybe my
first video on how digital images are
stored if i can remember that 255 would
be the most of that color that the
camera's seen a much younger version of
me we actually store them pixel wise rg
and b as little bytes within the pixel
but we don't do that when we put them
into deep networks we put them in as
three channels of input like this r
g and b or bgr whatever right now this
goes into the first layer of your
network and is convolved using a
convolution and so on right goes through
your network and so your network would
do some some convolutions and some
filtering and then it would make some
sort of decision produce some kind of
segmentation or whatever your downstream
task actually is or your your objective
now
in rgbd it's exactly the same we just
have an extra channel so we have r
g b
d so this is our depth map and then r g
and b
that's not a b
and you can put this into a network and
just
you know run it as normal right the
network in some sense doesn't care that
you've got four channels not three you
just have to change the first layer so
actually what you do is you have an
identical network
where you just reconfigure this very
first layer to take an input of four
instead of an input of three and that
will require retraining but it's not a
big task to do this
and you might find that if you do that
you you have some kind of performance
improvement right with the caveat that
you've got to have gone then had a real
sense or some other camera capture this
additional data right so
you'll find that people do this when
it's necessary to do this or useful to
do this not just because why not capture
depth right there is some there's some
headache in doing so also the depth map
might be bad right we saw when the
infrared drops down it gets less good
this is true outside when there is a
poor texture it's worth bearing in mind
now
some techniques separate the depth from
rgb so what they would do is they would
have an rgb a pathway like this and then
they'd have a set put d pathway
like this which does some processing and
maybe they join these together
for some kind of decision making right
and that's also quite common so the
reason you might do this is if you think
that the depth is in some way it
somewhere needs to be treated separately
to the rgb because it represents some
different data that might be what you do
right it's that kind of idea but you can
see it intuitively not difficult to
build depth information into a deep
network or into any image processing uh
pipeline and you usually get a bit of a
boost in performance giving it a depth
channel even though technically visa
means something different not really
that important as long as you train it
appropriately doesn't really matter you
might find some performance benefit of
keeping it separate for a while or some
other strategy but in some sense there's
no harm in doing it like the it's not
this they used to be quite expensive
stereo setups or difficult to configure
now this comes out of the box i plugged
it in and it immediately returned me a
depth map there was no calibration there
was no faffing about someone must have
calibrated it in the factory i guess so
i was surprised actually i thought it
would work worse than it did it worked
really really well
and so theoretically it's just there's
no big headache for me to just to use
this it produces rgb as well so i can
stream this directly and put it into my
deep learning albums and it's not an
expensive device it's you know we order
a few hundred pounds for these kind of
devices maybe less
and so that sort of consumer budget you
could see that it might
be something that people could actually
buy and make use of
that's a quantum bit so it's not just
zero or one it can be a mixture of zero
and one so what we have
is this
and this and we have some mixture we
have some super position machine
and see can't see or hear each other
they can't pick up each other's
transmissions